over a dozen former russian mcdonald's
locations reopened this past weekend
with different branding and a new name
bukushnu and tuchka or tasty and that's
it this comes after the american fast
food icon permanently left russia last
month following its invasion of ukraine
mcdonald said last month it would sell
847 russian locations to alexander gavor
who operated 24 franchise locations in
siberia
gavor who built his fortune in russia's
coal and oil sectors would not tell
forbes russia in a recent interview how
much he paid for the restaurants but he
did say he had competition and he hopes
to expand to 1 000 restaurants in the
country within the next few years the
menu in the new stores is largely
similar but they cannot sell branded
items such as big macs or mcflurries due
to trademarks mcdonald's holds
historical significance in russia as it
was one of the first western brands to
open in the former soviet union the
first location opened in 1990 and
moscow's pushkin square shortly after
the fall of the berlin wall that
location and 14 others opened up on june
12th with the new name and branding 50
more debuted on june 13th the new
company told reuters they plan to have
all of the former russian mcdonald's
locations transformed by the end of
summer